à
d'd'ici la fin de l'est de
didissoudre le Parlement et de
lalancer la campagne électorale.
- - Merci.
G Ghyslain Picard, le chef
dede l'Assemblée des Premières
NaNations Québec-Labrador,
PePersonne d'origine a occupé?
- - Devenait inévitable convient
dedepuis plusieurs mois, plusies
anannées. L'hypothèse avait déjà
étété évoquée plusieurs fois
avavant. Je pense aujourd'hui
c'c'est le bon moment pour
prprocéder à une telle nominati.
IlIl y avait certainement pas de
cacandidate plus appropriée que
MaMary Simon
àà ce poste.
- - On a vu certains commentairs
susur représenter la reine,
séséparant quelque part recule,
quque ça envoie un message de
sosoumission? Est-ce que c'est
papartagé cette réflexion?
- - Il y aura des opinions qui
seseront très partagées par
rarapport à la fonction en tant
quque telle. Ce qui aurait pu
rereprésenter, reculons un demi-
sisiècle, et ce présente
auaujourd'hui, on l'a vu dans la
fofoulée, la grève de la faim, l
y y a une dizaine d'années, la
poportance qui était attachée pr
unune grande majorité de premièe
nanation l'échelle du pays, en
évévoquant le fait que c'était
MoMonsieur Johnson à l'époque, l
ététait directement le
rereprésentant de la reine. C'et
elelle qui a signé les traités
nonotamment avec les premières
nanations. Maintenant, les algis
sosont encore partagées
auaujourd'hui parce que de toute
évévidence il y a des limites qi
sese rapportent à cette fonctio,
lele niveau d'intervention
nonotamment et jusqu'où le bureu
dede la gouverneur général danse
cacas-ci peut aller. Il aura trs
cecertainement des défis
imimportants pour Madame Simondu
cocours des prochaines semainest
prprochains mois.
- - Elle aura à observer de
grgrandes réserves dans cette
fofonction. Peut faire vraiment
unune réelle différence?
- - Est arrivé au bon moment. My
SiSimon un parcours sans faille
dedepuis déjà plusieurs décenni.
PlPlus particulièrement au seine
sasa propre nation, la nation
ininouïe. Très impliqué comme
nénégociatrice au Nunavik.
ImImpliqué également niveau de a
didiplomatie canadienne. Je
l'l'avais rencontré à ce momentà
auau début des années 2000. Je
pepense qu'elle a un parcours
imimpressionnant comme personne
ttâtonne. La réconciliation, je
pepense que ça représente sûremt
unun défi important, mais
inintéressant.
- - Vous pensez qu'elle peut
paparticiper à ce rapprochement
enentre les peuples?
- - Dans la mesure où on parle
cecertes réserves qui évoluent u
bubureau de la gouverneur génér.
IlIl y a cet aspect là qui peut
sasans doute rapidement atterrir
susur son bureau comme étant une
cocommande importante et je pene
ququ'elle est tout à fait à la
hahauteur de sa, de cette
opopportunité.
- - Elle parle l'inuktitut,
l'l'anglais, mais ne parle pas
frfrançais mais s'engage à
l'l'apprendre. Voyez ce de
BoBonneuil ça pourrait quand mêe
lului nuire auprès des
frfrancophones au pays?
- - Si on part de bilinguisme,
elelle est. Si on ajoute à ça le
frfrançais, d'ailleurs moi la
coconnaissant, pas au u même tie
quque beaucoup d'autres personns
ququi l'ont côtoyé sans doute,
mamais je sais que si elle dit
ququ'elle va poursuivre ses étus
enen France, je sais qu'elle vae
fafaire.
- - Vous êtes à la première
asassemblée annuelle. Ce sont ds
élélections importantes?
- - Tout à fait surtout avec ce
coconvient depuis plusieurs
sesemaines, les sépultures sont,
àà Kamloops et ce n'est pas fin.
ToTout le monde le dit. On est
enencore là-dessus. C'est
imimportant, Tonnay porte moment
susurtout devant les élections
féfédérales qui bientôt ne
titiendront plus d'hypothèses.
JeJe pense que cette élection et
exextrême